this is the card on in the southern
French city of NIEM it houses a museum
of contemporary art and the city library
it faces a Roman temple that dates back
to the first century BC to celebrate the
20th anniversary of the completion of
the Chi sir norman foster is organized
an exhibition of some of his favorite
artwork
the exhibition is untitled moving it's
very intuitive so if a work of art moves
me emotionally or intellectually then
that is the criteria for the choice
hence the name moving foster is brought
together works created by the cream of
the international art world including
China's AI weiwei italian sculptor
umberto boccioni and germany's garage
Ishta museums from all over the world
have lent artworks for the exhibition
german visual artist andreas gursky is
also represented here the connections
between art architecture design the
design of cars aircraft furniture is one
totality obviously here I have to split
them so I concentrate on art but with my
family I live with the work of artists
and in a way this is perhaps a
continuation of the way that I view art
art lovers were fascinated at the idea
of one of the world's great architects
presenting artworks in one of his own
buildings the design is vintage foster
elaborate and translucent in fact the
library section uses almost exclusively
natural light it's a nine-story
structure but five of the floors are
underground Foster's choices of artwork
can be found throughout the building for
example this installation by Otto
eliasson
I think it's an inspiration i think the
links are perhaps more subliminal than
so i don't think you can see an
immediate direct connection but
certainly there are connections for me
as a as an architect in 1967 foster
founded the architectural firm that
still bears his name and employs a staff
of more than a thousand fosters
legendary works include the Swiss Re
headquarters building in London better
known as the gherkin and the hearst
tower in New York City the Mayo viaduct
in France and the dome of the Reichstag
building in Berlin but if we think of
the Reichstag the Reichstag is
inseparable as an architectural work
from the contributions of the many
artists Foster's exhibition at the
Coweta also features the work of
lesser-known artists that have attracted
his attention he finds their work moving
in keeping with the theme of the
exhibition and he wants it to reach a
wider audience
I'm hoping that really threw as it were
my eyes that I can open up to a wider
audience and there are no rules if I
feel that two works have some
relationship visually or emotionally
then I bring them together yes his own
ideas about art and you can see that at
the exhibition it's what he wants to
show not what's hot with the critics
right now it's office Berlin artist
Daniel leg on decorated this huge wall
in the Fourier of the car I on it
contains a number of references to
Foster's architectural designs
this museum the museum is a very open
structure and not just in an
architectural sense there's a library
activities for children on the first
floor and the museum above that I think
the structure is very interesting blooma
pintas I just talked to zentra son it
took sir norman foster nine years to
plan and design the calves edad he says
the exhibition has given him the
opportunity to see the structure in
brand new ways i return and see it in
its many different moods with different
exhibitions and for me that's very very
important process excuse me a very
important part of the process of
designing to see how a building weathers
over time how it changes with time how
it adapts so it's all part of a
continuous learning process this unique
blend of art and architecture will be
open to the public through September 15